hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game between two World Chess
Championship challengers Khurana being
the 2018 World Chess Championship
challenger and of course Karekin being
the 2016 World Chess Championship
challenger but before we talk about this
matchup a bit and of course we check out
the game we do have a nice photo
challenge so who is the little gentleman
in the photo
there you have it best of luck to
everyone and we also have a very nice
photo that really you know intrigued me
I do hope you enjoy it there you have it
it's a photo by - a - of Kiwanis fans
the gentleman on the left there you have
hit he has a nice t-shirt for the 2018
Crossan versus Khurana championship
saying bring it home and on the right
you have also a gentleman that as you
can see carries around a huge Fabiano
Caruana head with him so there
definitely some excellent support going
on there and would fans like these what
what could possibly go wrong
so I do hope you enjoyed that now let's
let's see how the game went Khurana here
has the white pieces and it's very
interesting as they go for kurakin goes
for the nimzo-indian defense the
fortnight to f6
c4 e6 Knight to c3 and here you can see
that the game did start with the d4 so
obviously Caruana is interested in a
fight and by allowing this name is o
Indian Bishop to b4 kurakin is also very
much up for fight and here we have g3 a
move that has been very present lately
and the White has been trying to refute
the nimzo-indian with this move order
we have castles push up to g2 and the d5
now Knight to f3 D captors on c4 we have
castles in the night the c6 so this has
all been played plenty of times
Queen to a4 and the now comes Bishop to
d7
we have Bishop to g5 and now a5 this a5
move has never been played before it's
probably or maybe something that car can
prepared but it's a the engine doesn't
mind in this mode the engine says it's
it's a fine move I personally don't like
it but you know Who am I to judge moves
but I don't like it simply because it's
a poem once you push up onto a five you
know you can never move it back and I
don't really see what the point is doing
there it seems like really seems like an
engine move but okay Khurana finds the
best reputation for this idea he plays
Bishop captures on f6 Queen captures and
now a3 as correct ended push a5 now he
can simply ask you know what are the
future whereabouts of this Bishop so you
can either capture or move the bishop
back here Bishop captures and c3 was
played but you also have to figure out
whether to go for this very very
interesting Knight captures on d4 move
which would open up a discovered attack
here now what will happen if car can
went for this if Knight captures on d4
of course Queen captures only seven now
comes Bishop captures on c3 pawn
captures in the night captures on e2
with check King moves and now Knight
captures on c3 so you sacrificed a piece
but you have three points in return so
far four points it's eight points to
four but of course Queen can capture on
c7 for example Queen captures now b5
rook to e1 and the other comes to c8 and
it seems like a very interesting not an
exchange sacrifice but it's not really
even a sacrifice you have three points
for the piece and you know three
connected pawns so this could be very
interesting in the future I mean some
players would definitely enjoy playing
playing this with the black pieces but
okay after a three Bishop CalPERS on c3
was played be captures and c3 and while
car cane can still go for this idea
instead he goes Queen to d8 he doesn't
he is not interested in this we have
Queen captures on c4 and now comes a
400k Kerrigan prefers this plan now this
a five to a four starts making sense
a knight is coming to a5 and then he
created a nice outpost for this night on
B three nights the d2 karana already
prepares as he knows this Knight wants
to find an output nice out person b3 so
he puts his knight on D two also opens
up he's a very strong light square
bishop here nice to a5 wouldn't attack
on
Queen Queen to be seven pressuring the
b7 pawn as now it's attacked twice and
now look to a7 now we have rook a to b 1
and now b6 as the rook is no longer an
a8 we have III and now c4 sorry Bishop
to c6 Bishop captures on c6 Knight
captures on c6 enter now Queen to b5
attacking the knight on c6 coming to a 8
and the now comes c4 so kirkin manages
to keep everything in order but he's you
know his pieces are very passive the
knight isn't all that great on c6 the
queen is stuck on a8 guarding the night
you still have to figure out what to do
with this rook so not not the greatest
you know of positions for black you
could immediately play rook to a5 to
take away the queen but kirkin first
goes to work to the 8th he develops the
rook I will have rook F 2 c1 and now
comes in 5 of course you don't want to
allow this exchange so why not push a
bond and we have d5 attacking carbines
night nice to be 8 pushing curtains
pieces even further back and now c5 and
okay this is a beautiful temporary pawn
sacrifice that will result in a lot of
complications rook to a5 first attacking
the Queen Queen moves and now Queen
captures on d5 pawn captures on b6 we
have pawn captures on b6 and now Knight
to c4 attacking the rook and also the
pawn on d6 twice so we have rook to c5
we have Queen captures on b6 and here
you have to decide what to do of course
this is not a free night of course for
example if you capture it you get rogue
capture screen captures and Queen
captures on D 8 will be checkmate as
this rook is undefended but what are
some of your other options well there
really aren't all that many rook to f8
is a move that has to be played roof to
f8 and you have to allow this Queen
captures on b8
of course now you will not capture the
Queen as of this will once again result
in checkmate because black has so many
back rank weaknesses after you give up
all the material here it will result
once again in checkmate
but after this rook to f8 move you have
to allow this and then capture on c4
but the problem now is after rook
captures Queen captures Fabiano will
capture on e5 and black will lose upon
here and here Kerrigan will be suffering
for a very very long time for a couple
of more hours as he's down upon but he
would have the opportunity to prove his
title as as being the Minister of
Defense but instead here kirkin thought
that he had this luxury of playing f6
simply creating an escape square for the
King and while this does the create an
escape square for the king
it loses in so many other ways so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find not one but rather two
continuations that allow Caruana to take
advantage of this f6 move i'll give it a
couple of seconds first to decide where
we want to do it or not as usual so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you have just defeated
the Minister of Defence and for those
who just want to enjoy the show Korona
played rook to d1 but efore seems to be
an even greater move first let's see the
move Caruana did not play E for the
Queen has to keep an eye on the c5 rook
and on the d8 rock both rooks our
undefended and also you have to keep an
eye on this night because of so many
back ranked weaknesses so here after the
queen is attacked Queen to d4 a square
that allows the Queen to keep an eye on
both rooks but now comes Queen to e6
check and now it doesn't matter if the
King goes to f8 or h8 everything both
lose to the same ID and Knight to d6 and
now you can see that the knight is
threatening to come to f7 which will
result in a smothered smothered mate and
there really isn't all that much you can
do here if you play rook captures on c1
with check rook captures again there is
no defense against the knight to f7
check yeah so you you will either at
least you know lose the game in a
terrible way which is which is terrible
I mean if you capture tonight then like
we said there are simply too many back
ranked weaknesses this would result in
checkmate and even if you go with a
different move order if you don't
capture on c1 if you go for Queen
captures on b6 immediately still too
many back rank we
you can't even afford to capture here
now once again this will result in
checkmate rock who goes back rock
capture sandy eight and once again this
is checkmate
but karana didn't enjoy this move order
after f6 he played rook to d1 which
pretty much is the same thing it's hard
to say why why Cara can play this it's
it's unimaginable that kurakin would
miss rook to d1 which okay with efore
you I mean I mean it's very hard to
imagine but okay rook to d1 and now you
don't have any options if you move the
Queen rook captures rook which will
result in checkmate and of course if you
capture on D 1 which is what Cara can
played rock characters only one rook
after Sundy one here Fabiano played King
to g2 and it was in this position
unmoved 30 that Sergey Kerrigan resigned
in the game why did you resign well your
rope is under attack on c5 and also your
knight is under attack on b8 do you only
move that protects the both both of
these pieces is Knight to d7 and now
after Queen to e6 check you have two
options either you will go to a trade
and then you're getting checkmate it
after Knight f8 Queen captures on a fate
will be checkmate and on the other hand
after this Queen to e6 check you could
go to f8 but then again Knight to d6 you
will still lose to this this idea again
there's the threat of checkmate and you
have no options here you have to give up
the rook for the night Queen captures
with check and after King yet Queen e6
King moves for example check King moves
Queen captures on h7 I will also lose a
lot of these pawns and then white is up
simply too much material with all the
points on the King side white will
easily win this game so but it's also
very strange that after this after this
f6 move corona didn't go for efore
although there don't there doesn't seem
to be any moves that can complicate a
life for for Caruana seems like a much
cleaner weight and rook to d1 but I'm
sure he saw a lot of reasons why to play
rook to d1 instead so that's the game
from around six of the 2018 since the
single cup between two World
Championship challengers I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Dennis
Tomlinson Joseph Burnett Alexandra poor
and Jack never the third and the David
domine a follower for contrition to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it and it's very interesting
let's just check out something here here
you have defined the current standings
after round six so it's a Fabiana karana
in first place now so leader with four
points then Carson with three and a half
Grisha with three and a half Mahmoud our
oven our way and also by three and a
half then Maxine was Cheryl a girl with
three Allen with three was Lisa with
two-and-a-half Nakamura which two and
Sergey Kerrigan who is having probably
the worst third tournament in a very
long time in last place and also we have
this year
so today well like as I'm uploading the
video now like in an hour
this game will start we will have in
round 7 Magnus Carlsen versus Fabiana
Caruana so as you can see so far they
have played 10 games that Carlson won
five games that Caruana 1 and 17 of
those that were drawn in 2014 you can
see that Caruana won a game in the
sinful Cup in 2015
Carson 1 and in 2017 was a draw but one
of the most interesting things we do
have this nice preview or these are the
live ratings so as you can see our call
sign is on minus 6 and 6 point 4 and
karana is on plus 6 point to do so in
their next game in the sink filled cup
if Caruana manages to beat across and
with the black pieces in the live
ratings he he might overtake Carlsen
know if he wins the game he will
overtake Carlsen as the number one
highest rated player in the world
but of course that still means nothing
he still has to finish the tournament
without you know losing any games or you
know after that game he will still have
to win at least as many points in
Carlson to you know keep that advantage
and then he has to keep that advantage
up until the next you know rating
until the first in the next month but it
would be very interesting because magnus
carlsen has been the highest rated
player in the world ever since 2011 I
believe so it will definitely you know
shake the chess world but yeah that's
basically it I do hope you enjoyed it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
hopefully I'll see you soon with another
nice video you know it will either be
from the Bobby Fischer series or the
sinful Cup but either way as you know as
it is happening now it will be an
Americans you know conquest of the chest
only Olympus so once again thank you all
and I'll see you soon